reasontv presents citizens against
government waste porker of the month
Alabama Senator Richard Shelby President
Obama in effect pull the plug on our
space program not exactly fly me to the
moon Shelby is fighting President
Obama's plan to scrap constellation the
bush-era program that was intended to
replace the shuttle and modernize NASA
but the constellation program was not
fulfilling its promise in many ways was
behind schedule and over budget Obama
wants to rely more on competition
between space entrepreneurs it's
hopefully just the beginning of the most
fantastic program but Shelby isn't
having it a welfare program by the
commercial space industry so a
co-sponsor to measure protecting
constellation which was attached to an
emergency war funding bill ensuring
millions of taxpayer dollars continue
flying towards politically connected
NASA contractors like Alabama's own
radiance technologies which just happens
to be one of Senator Shelby's biggest
campaign contributors that's disturbing
Houston where you have a porker more
information on quarter of the month and
other government waste issues visit CA
GW org
you